tu ne vous aime pas vendredi dernier
l'émission village médias sur europe 1
recevez des auteurs du livre la part du
ghetto manon kerrouche brunel et malek
de woods dans l'émission il raconté que
les émissions de m6 serait très regardée
en prison et d'ailleurs nous aussi on
est très regardé et on embrasse un an
toutes les personnes pour qui on est un
bol d'air voilà tous les soirs ce soit
dans les prisons que ce soit dans les
hôpitaux ce soit des personnes voilà qui
sont voilà qui sont en bad qui sont un
petit peu en dépression et c'est vrai
qu'on veut toujours que tpm paix reste
ce bol d'air aux sports à vous si on
peut vous amener un petit peu de bonheur
tous les soirs et bentégeat on aura fait
vraiment tout ce qu il en garde c'est
vrai que comme on dit voilà on a là on
pense à vous vraiment tous les soirs je
vous jure que c'est vrai alors dans
l'émission a raconté que les émissions
de m6 serait très regardé donc en prison
notamment enquête exclusive ou 66
minutes et apprennent apparemment
beaucoup de choses alors c'est ce qu'ils
disent dans leur lit parce que vous êtes
d'accord avec eux ou pas ce que vous
aimez ou est-ce que vous n'avez pas
cette théorie je vous montrais de trois
extraits ensuite et vous allez nous dire
regarde on regarde beaucoup m6 en prison
c'est vrai notamment enquête exclusive
ou en quête d'action et donc qu'ils ont
ce s'appuie là-dessus pour apprendre des
erreurs de ceux qui sont tombés 10
apprennent à la façon dont il faut
parler à une juge pour éviter de prendre
de trop cher il explique aussi que
clairement il faut plus rien cacher à la
maison se dire que maintenant les flics
ils arrivent ils éventrent les armoiries
vide les frigos donc on ne cache plus la
drogue à la maison ici ils ont aussi
appris que quand gina les relevés
téléphoniques ne remonte pas à plus de
trois mois donc il dit tout ce qui s'est
passé avant puisqu'il n'y aura aucune
preuve de toute façon et ça ils l'ont
appris grâce à bernard de la villardière
à la mer cimer n'a alors c'est ce qui
laisse à leurs théories j'aime jetpack
et 10e aux petites pancartes vous jugez
vous mettez j'aime pas donc oui c'est
sauver non je pense pareil on a compris
alors je montrais pas l'ombre 2013
envoyée spéciale vous apprenez comment
braquer un distributeur à billets en
toute discrétion avec une méthode bien
ficelé regarde aujourd'hui franck ne
s'attaquent plus aux distributeurs
mais il a accepté de nous montrer les
failles de la carte bancaire
sur ce type de distributeur caisse
spécifique à cette banque
on va avoir un faux plafond c'est
l'avenir qui à venir se poser ici au
dessus puis plus ici un petit cache
qu'on va imposer sur un ratio
distributeur qui va nous permettre de
récolter les données la carte bancaire
il ya la famille limette de jeu entre
entre la bouche distributeurs ce qui va
nous permette de clic c'est parfaitement
le dispositif et son qui bouge alors que
vous l'ayez montrer parce que moi je me
souviens très bien de ce reportage il
montrait aussi des faux claviers il faut
quelques secondes pour mettre l'avenir
toutes les chaînes mais c'est sympa
parce que ça fait des exercices rappelle
aussi qu'elle a un truc sur les arbres à
tout à l'heure ce sera faire l'émission
non franchement mais qui là en ayant vu
cet extrait dans les minutes qui suivent
aller chercher une lime
non mais mesurée c'est ridicule depuis
la nuit des temps il ya des reportages
comme ça voilà celui qui veut il se
renseigne dans la rue mais il n'a pas
besoin de reporter vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec eux mêmes que je suis pas
d'accord par contre nous ça nous on est
beaucoup plus prudent en voyant ça en
voyant les méthodes en disant bon j'ai
vu ça je vais faire attention encore et
il fait tu fais un petit côté agité veut
me voir tout à l'heure mignon jeu alors
alors dimanche dernier dans sept à huit
on a pu voir également cette envie de
s'intéresser à la maison d'arrêt de
versailles
et comment faire simplement rentrer un
téléphone dans une prison regarde
pendant 30 minutes elle inspecte les
moindres recoins des neuf mètres carrés
la surveillante fou et même les endroits
peu ragoûtant seule une dizaine de
portables et retrouver chaque année en
cellule elles sont nombreuses à nous
avons et détenir un portable comme
nathalie
le portable de 7 cm coûte 30 euros
et si vous arrivez chez vous bref voilà
alors donc il est reproché à ces
reportages de donner des idées vous vous
êtes d'accord j'ai vu ce que le disent
parce que ça paraît très objectif que
des émissions de faits divers donne des
idées à des aides à des délinquants
pardon c'est tout à fait probable
en revanche à ce qu'ils apprennent le
métier par le biais de ses émissions je
crois que c'est exagéré
ce n'est qu'une ébauche de la réalité je
me rappelle qu'en avril 2010 cette
enquête et sujet s'était intéressé à
autre voiture volée 2-1 spécial voiture
volée c'était pas larié tam en regard
des patchs auriel regarder alors la
canebière le but pour les malfaiteurs
reprogrammer ces cartes de démarrage 9
en fonction du véhicule volé là nous
avons un logiciel qui s'élançait donc là
un soir renaud la partie qui nous
intéresse est là il suffit juste faire
de m la carte est de faire ajouter
nouvelles cartes vont alors les
débloquer
les pharmas force il expliqué des
pratiques alors géraldine moi je trouve
ça naïf démago et je pense pas qu'on
fasse de la prévention avec une
télévision aseptisé et c'est très naïf
de penser que les délinquants
le bandit le terrorisme attention je ne
peux rien faire parce que j'attends de
programmes de bernard de la villardière
ou alors que c'est sa s'empare de ces
choses là puisque le csa est censé à
faire des choses utiles pour la
télévision française
ils disent menacés c'est dangereux et
donc attention